[Aplausos]
el mundo le dio la bienvenida al nuevo
presidente electo de eeuu en américa las
felicitaciones llegaron por parte de los
mandatarios desde canadá hasta chile
incluso venezuela sumida en prolongadas
tensiones con washington venezuela la
patria del libertador simón bolívar
siempre estará dispuesta al diálogo y al
entendimiento con el pueblo y el
gobierno de los eeuu
el presidente brasileño jair bolsonaro
cercano al presidente camps decidió
guardar silencio así lo reportaron
fuentes cercanas hasta esperar un cuadro
completo de los resultados méxico tuvo
una reacción similar vamos nosotros
terminen
y resolver todos los asuntos
y legales no queremos ser imprudentes
luego de que los medios de comunicación
estadounidenses anunciaron la victoria
de byd en twitter fue la plataforma
escogida por los líderes mundiales para
enviar sus mensajes los europeos con
quien el presidente truman tenía
disputas en materia comercial y cambio
climático se mostraron deseosos de
trabajar en una agenda conjunta con byd
en la alcaldesa de parís anne hidalgo
recordó la promesa de campaña del líder
demócrata sobre traer a eeuu de vuelta
al acuerdo de parís cuya salida se
oficializó esta semana bienvenido de
nuevo eeuu felicitaciones al joe biden y
kamala harris por su elección mientras
estamos a punto de celebrar el quinto
aniversario del acuerdo de parís
esta victoria simboliza nuestra
necesidad de actuar juntos más que nunca
en vista a la emergencia climática
medio-oriente no fue la excepción
pakistán jordania e iraq coincidieron en
la búsqueda de una agenda en común que
permita paz y estabilidad en la región
donde eeuu ha tenido fuerte presencia en
su lucha contra el estado islámico y el
programa nuclear de irán